death they say is the only certainty in
life but how and when to die these are
questions that modern medicine gives us
more control over than ever before
as a renowned neurosurgeon henry marsh
dealt more in life and death than most
now as a patient he knows all too well
the fate that may await him i am as you
said an informed consumer i've got
advanced prostate cancer it's in
remission at the moment but ironically
enough i must have operated upon
hundreds of men with advanced prostate
cancer which had spread to the spine and
this causes progressive paralysis so a
large number of men with prostate cancer
die
paralyzed doubly incontinent bedridden
i want some choice in the matter
assisted dying is currently illegal in
the uk the last attempt to change that
via a bill in the house of lords failed
in april shortly afterwards a petition
to legalize it reached a hundred
thousand signatures it will be debated
in the house of commons later today
and there's evidence of a striking
mismatch between public opinion and that
of mps a yougov poll last year found
that whilst 73 percent of people thought
assisted dying should be legalized for
the terminally ill just 35 of mps agreed
others argue that the answer lies not in
changing the law but in improving
palliative care the health service can
and estimates are that 320 people a day
don't have the right end-of-life care
and that's really shocking many of the
heartbreaking stories that we hear
driving the assisted suicide debate are
of people who sadly did not get the
right palliative care and did not have
access to the best support at the time
of their dying or their loved ones dying
either way if the law is to change it
will require more than petitions it will
require government will something that
until now has been absent for good or
for ill matthew thompson sky news